Republicans have tried and failed to
censure Democratic congressmen and
recent guests on the David packman show
Adam Schiff there's something really
funny going on and the details of the
Adam Schiff things like I could tell you
exactly how it failed and what they were
trying to do it doesn't even matter
because these aren't serious people
Republicans particularly Mega trumpists
right now are desperate to find someone
on the left that they can punish or
charge or convict or indict
that uh they have not been able to
actually find they might not stop until
they're either out of power or they
finally get someone in trouble but it is
so Brazen and so transparent and so
pathetic